record-breaking inflation squeezed
Public Services a conservative
government that went from promising the
biggest tax cuts in 50 years to taking
the country's tax burden to its highest
level since the second world war so what
is the plan I speak to the person in
charge of the public pass Jeremy Hunt
[Music]
hello and welcome to Beth Rigby
interviews just last week we saw the new
Chancellor deliver his Autumn statement
in an effort to restore stability and
confidence in the UK finances but the
political skill of Thursday's statement
can't detract from the hard reality of
what people are about to face with
squeezed Public Services rise in taxes
plus soaring food and energy bills the
cost of living crisis has its grips
firmly on this country the washing
machine are having to turn off now but
I'm not using it the cookers now turned
off at the wall but I'm not using it the
same with the microwave and the airfryer
the pound which was up at around kind of
one dollar and eight cents has now
fallen by kind of you know almost two
cents the pound has hit the lowest level
ever it's not actually you know it's
actually the lowest ever it's not just
since decimalization it's the lowest
since since the invention of the pound
it's too much money going into gas and
electric what is it you feed your child
or you don't feed your child I want to
be completely Frank about the scale of
the economic challenge we face it's a
historic moment for inflation because
it's got up to the highest level that
we've seen since the 1980s have a look
at that 11.1 percent higher than
economists that expected higher since
1981 we need to take decisive action at
home to get our borrowing and debt on a
sustain
we'll do that because
that tackle inflation it will help us
cut the costs of things that will help
us limit the increase in mortgage rate I
had a 92 year old man two weeks ago who
went out into his garden and shouted for
help she got no food
it's not something I want to deal with
terrific it's affecting everybody today
we deliver a plan to tackle the cost of
living crisis and rebuild our economy
but it means taking difficult decisions
there just isn't enough money to go
around basically I'm doing more hours so
I'm doing like 60 plus hours a week and
it seems to be going in taxes
so and it still just isn't enough I sat
down with Jeremy Hunt to ask him the
tough questions about the future of our
economy and the future of the
conservative government
Chancellor thank you very much for
joining us on on the show today and I
want to start off with you as an MP for
17 years you've been a cabinet minister
on and off for the best part of a decade
and you know all too well better than
most that economic competence is Central
to the Tory party brand and what voters
associate your party with isn't the
truth that what has happened recently
and a bit beyond that has damaged that
reputation that it's taken a hit and
that actually your reputation for
economic competencies in tatters at the
moment I think that's overstating it but
I I do accept
that you know we've had a rocky period
in the last couple of months I wish that
we hadn't had what happened with the
mini budget and all the turbulence that
happened there but you're absolutely
right and I became a member of the
conservative party when I think I was 20
years old because I thought ours is the
party that takes the tough and difficult
decisions that mean that we can be a
prosperous country can pay for the NHS
our schools all those things and I think
the conservatives are the only party
that take those decisions and that was
really what I was doing on Thursday I
was saying that we all know how
difficult it is but if we want this to
be one of the most prosperous countries
in Europe we've got to face up to the
challenges we face and we've got to do
it Square on and so I hope
British people who you know won't have
liked seeing their taxes go up will have
been worried about some of the cuts in
the growth in public spending I hope
they understand the purpose of this
wasn't just a misery for misery's sake
it was to make sure that we really have
that bright future that everyone wants
and transfer I'm going to get on on to
sort of more of the detail of the Autumn
Stone some of the decisions you made
but also the British people would have
been watching that mini budget thinking
hang on a minute part of these is has
been caused by the catastrophic budget
mini or otherwise that was Unleashed
just a few weeks earlier by
quasiquartang it was if you like the
most catastrophic moment I think in
recent political history and certainly
for the conservative party economically
do you accept that the party is
responsible for that this isn't just
about global economic headwinds those
are domestic element and it was
self-harmed by your party that has put
the British public in this situation
well I accept that there was turbulence
and as I say I regret it but we reverse
those decisions I did it within three
days of becoming Chancellor and I think
just three weeks after they'd originally
been announced and the money that
matters to the country is what we have
to pay to service our our very big
national debt and the rates we pay for
that are now below what they were before
the mini budget so I think the long-term
challenges we Face are really the same
as as Germany which has had a bigger
downgrade in its growth forecasts Italy
and France that are restricting their
borrowing America that's seen higher
increases in their mortgage rates and
this is really because of the pandemic
and Ukraine it partly is but there was a
domestic element in it and you're
actually not denying that you're
accepting that how much damage did Liz
truss and cozy quatang do to the economy
in in number terms well as I say I don't
believe there was a long-term impact
because the measures they introduced
were reversed so quickly I think what
the world wanted to see was that the
United Kingdom was not going to spend
money it didn't have and was committed
to repaying its debts and British sunak
and myself have given them that
reassurance and I think that's why you
see what's happened in the markets very
much settled down unfortunately though
the big challenges we face with the
global energy crisis with the
interruptions to supply chains following
the pandemic they mean that that isn't
the only thing that we have to deal with
we have to deal with those much bigger
issues and that's what we're trying to
do
Foundation did put a number on it and if
you'll see it they said it was a 30
billion pound hit which was a mix of the
tax Rises also the tax cuts some of
which you've now reversed and also a 10
billion pound hit which was the result
of the market reaction so there was
something you needed to correct you said
you regret it are you sorry for it don't
you think it's not your fault well I
don't recognize those resolution
Foundation figures because the the tax
measures in the mini budget were largely
reversed so I I don't accept that
analysis
um look I take responsibility for the
British economy me under my party's
management over the last 12 years and if
you look at the bigger picture in a
12-year period in which we've had three
enormous shocks a global financial
crisis a pandemic and a global energy
crisis we've actually had a third
highest growth in the G7 faster than
France Germany faster than Japan or
Italy and so I think I'm you know
overall that is a very creditable
economic performance which I think is
what people expect from a conservative
government I'm going to ask you more
thing I'm going to move on I asked the
Prime Minister whether he'd apologize
for what happened given the turmoil it
caused and the the anxiety caused people
he he declined to do that would would
you like to apologize or do you think
that that is something you don't need to
do that regret is enough well I think in
politics actions speak louder than words
and I became Chancellor within three
days had reversed those measures in the
mini budget and very soon after that the
money that we have to pay as a country
to pay for our national debt went down
to the levels of the mini budget before
it so I think we have demonstrated that
we think what happened was wrong yeah
we've corrected it and we put the
country back on the right track okay
well let's move on
um to the UK economy and growth now in
your Autumn statement you said your
priorities were stability growth and
public services but the elephant in the
room to all of this is brexit we don't
talk about it much it's almost become a
taboo subject journalists aren't even
asked allowed to really ask questions
about it without feeling like you're
somehow attacking brexit but it's heart
the economy what do you think the hit
the UK economy will be because of brexit
well brexit was a change in our trading
relations with our biggest single
trading partner I've always believed in
fact I believed even before the brexit
vote that we could make a great success
of brexit I think there's no reason why
we can't be like you want to brexit here
no I was worried about the uh the
Constitutional risks but economically
I've always believed we can make a
tremendous success of it and we could be
like Canada or Australia or Japan
smaller countries that absolutely throw
Drive outside a big trading block but
let me answer your question it is a
change okay well me I don't accept
that brexit is the cause of the big
economic difficulties we face and let me
give you an example as to why I don't
know what the ibr figures are wrong but
let me let me answer the question back
because you know Germany
has seen its growth forecasts downgraded
by 4.8 percent uh compared to us who've
seen our growth downgraded by three
percent so you're seeing countries like
Austria Netherlands Italy that have
higher inflation than us what we're
seeing are Global factors that are
causing a shock to all major I know but
people people watching this are worried
about their own household incomes and
their own economy and economic growth in
the UK
the obr what has the obr forecast you
know this about brexit well the the obr
say that absent other changes uh in I
think it's a decade's time uh we will
grow less fast than we would have done
by 30 but yes four percent median term
GDP four percent lower than it otherwise
would have been yes absent other changes
and my point is I think that there are
lots of things we can do actually things
that I announced in My Autumn statement
when I talked about us becoming the
world's next Silicon Valley using brexit
freedoms to make sure that we change
regulations in areas like uh the
development of new medicines or
artificial intelligence or all the
really big things that are going to
shape the 21st century actually being
able to set your own regulations means
that you can do some of those things in
a way that wouldn't have been possible
inside but you fill the whole of the
economic scarring can you fill the hole
more than
because in the end brexit is a choice
that Britain as a country made and
whether we would make a success of it or
not is a choice that we now have to make
and what I outlined on Thursday for
families up and down the country who are
worried about their mortgages worried
about the shopping bills some short-term
help
but also a long-term Vision as to how we
can be very successful let me just if
you allow me to let me just go back
because the four percent of GDP you're a
Chancellor that's desperately needing
growth in order to grow the economy to
increase the tax takes to cut our taxes
to increase spending in public services
growth is Central to all of that we all
know that how much lost income and tax
revenue does that four percent over the
medium term add up to you'll know the
figure
um Beth I don't accept the four percent
that four percent is a figure that it
says that the obr figures sometimes such
as inflation you're happy to take that
one yes I don't have to accept all of
them and that's one that I set the ones
you like well I accept the ones I agree
with and I don't accept the ones I don't
agree with in that one I don't agree
with because that is saying absent other
changes uh that could be the impact and
I think we announced some very big
changes in the Autumn saying no no no
you can't just start because then you're
moving on from
well then you need to let me answer give
you answers maybe uh you weren't hoping
to hear but what I outlined in the
Autumn statement was a plan for how we
get to the other side and it's really
important because families are very very
worried about the the pressures they're
under they're seeing their energy bills
go up and so on and what you if you look
at those Obi figures that you were
coaching the obr just now what do they
actually say the biggest worry for
families is prices going up they say
inflation is going to halve and then
actually go down to zero in the next two
to three years they say that growth the
other side will be growing between two
and three percent for the following
three years so what they show is that
the decisions that I made mean that the
recession the impact on GDP is much less
than it would have been and there's a
lot of growth the other side and I will
come I I have lots of questions on the
also I just want to quickly go back to
this point on brexit because these
numbers that you don't expect from the
except from the Independent forecast the
ABR that four percent GDP reduction over
the longer term amounts to about a
hundred billion pounds in Lost trade and
approximately 40 billion pounds in tax
revenue I mean people watching this will
say say did we vote to become poorer
because of brexit they might conclude
that you have not made a success of this
well do you accept those figures or you
just do not accept them no I think I've
said to you probably three times now
that those are what the obr project if
we don't do other things to take
advantage of the opportunities or brexit
and what I announced on Thursday are the
things that we are going to do let me
give you another example of one of the
things that we are absolutely determined
to do with in order to make a success of
brexit people are worried and a lot of
people voted for brexit are worried
about high levels of migration and what
we've said is that we want to use the
moment of brexit to move our economy to
become a high skill high-wage economy so
that we have less dependence on
migration and what I announced on
Thursday was a big program to look at
our skills program now if we can invest
in the skills of our own people reduce
the pressures on migration then we are
taking advantage of that change the
chance to become a high-wage economy and
I think that is what people voted for
perhaps it happened what nearly three
years ago the UK has just announced
record migration numbers today well so
the public look at this going oh yeah
you're going to reduce net migration
there are record migration figures and
we're poorer because of brexit according
to the obr figures you don't accept well
I think there are very specific reasons
for the migration figures today half
that increase is students and then the
other half is people coming from Ukraine
from Afghanistan from Hong Kong those
are our International obligations but
people understand that if we want to
reduce that need for migration over the
longer term we have to invest in skills
and that is the big change now we've had
you know within months of Legally
leaving the European Union we had a once
in a century pandemic and the
government's Focus absolutely rightly in
those two years was saving the lives
that were put at risk by covid but now
we put the pandemic largely behind us
and my statement on Thursday showed how
we are going to forge a different
economy outside the European Union High
skill High wage the world's next Silicon
Valley with our own regulations and I
believe we can do that because I think
we've got an incredible country I'm
going to come on to the Autumn state but
I just adjust on brexit the final thing
I wanted to ask you about was this from
the Obi are the latest evidence suggests
that brexit has had a significant
adverse impact on UK trade for reducing
both overall trade volumes and the
number of trading relationships between
UK and EU Farms do you accept trade as
being dramatically hit and can you
understand why some business people now
have to stop trading with the EU or
relocate as a former entrepreneur
yourself
it's quite painful for them isn't it
except there is a transition for
businesses because we voted as a country
to change our trading relationship with
the EU that was a decision the whole
country made we had a a proper
Democratic process and there is a change
and you know that transition
obviously presents difficulties for some
businesses what I don't accept is that
the long-term impact of that decision
will be to make us poorer quite the
opposite I think there are big
opportunities for us to come much more
wealthy than we would otherwise have
been those are the opportunities that I
want to embrace as a journalist all I
can work on are independent forecast by
the obr rather than the promises that
that you're making about brexit and I
think viewers will look at this and say
well the ABR said there's this hit gdpu
is the chancellor are not acceptable as
long as you're making clear Beth that
the obr was talking about what the
potential theoretical hang on let me
finish yeah the potential theoretical
hit might be in 10 years time and as
long as you're also recognizing that the
government thinks that we can make sure
that doesn't happen and finally as
you're talking about the obr as long as
you're recognizing that they say that
when we get through the recession in the
next year and a half we're going to be
growing at a very healthy two to three
percent a year for the three years
but you've got to remember I'm running
out of time already let's just quickly
go
so how could you mitigate it and one of
the things is ease and trade with the EU
you said last week I'm fed to trade with
neighbors and countries around the world
is very beneficial to growth you spoke
about being able to remove the vast
majority of trade barriers with the EU
but you also have ruled out a Swiss
style deal which could include
regulatory alignment in order to have
more frictionless trade
what would be the effect on the economy
if we did have a Swiss style deal well
that is not the right deal for the UK
because as I announced on Thursday we
are going to pursue different
regulations as an independent sovereign
country but I'd just like to make a
point Beth you know we've got a
20-minute interview and you've chosen to
spend a huge amount of time talking
about brexit when actually no no when
actually if you look at what the oecd
say if you look at what the obr say they
say the biggest reason for the decline
in our economic picture is high
International Energy prices and you
haven't asked me anything about the big
plans that we announced for energy
not with me and not in this interview
and and I if I may say I think I'm happy
to take a few minutes
I'm happy to talk about the things that
matter the obr did not say that brexit
was the principal cause for the
difficulties we faced they said that was
International Energy prices and the
economic shocks we've had over the last
15 years from the um from the pandemic
and the global financial crisis as well
as what's happened in Ukraine now what
we announced on Thursday was a set of
measures to deal with those shocks so
that we can reassure families
particularly about their energy bills
short-term help 900 pounds this year 500
pounds next year for the average family
but then after that a long-term plan to
reduce our energy dependency on what
Putin may choose to do with his
neighboring country so I think if I may
say I think those are the things that
your viewers need to hear about because
they're what on the oecd and the obr and
all these independent bodies they're
what they those are the things that they
say are causing our economics final
thing that I quickly move on find the
thing on brexit yes because
brexit is not the issue that all these
independent commentators are talking
about when they talk about challenges
facing the British economy so I'll
answer your question
will be economically good but
politically undeliverable in your view
that's my final question no because uh
if we had a deal like Switzerland have
then we wouldn't have the opportunity to
set our own regulations and become the
world's next Silicon Valley which is my
long-term plan for the British economy
to make sure that we can fund things
like the NHS in the future okay I want
to just quickly go on to the Autumn
statement I'm not I haven't got much
time left
um
Esther McVay who was going to be your
Deputy Prime Minister had you when you
were going to start well you did stand
in July you're going to have Esther as
your Deputy Prime Minister she thinks
that you have made political choices in
this budget and over corrected her
argument is that Liz Tross was driving
the car off the road if you like you're
now driving it into the central
reservation over correcting and there
was another way which was a middle pass
she said the Autumn statement was an
over correction to that mini budget
going from one extreme to the other is
hardly reassuring for people a middle
ground was needed what's your response
to that to colleagues and the public
that think you've gone too far well
um my response first of all Esther is a
brilliant colleague I think the world of
her I have great admiration for her and
uh I think she's a fantastic campaigner
but
the charge of over correction is not
worn out by what the independent obr
says they say of the measure they say
that the measures that I announced
actually make the recession shallower
that the fall in GDP which could damage
people's living standards threaten jobs
is one percent less as a result of the
decisions that I announced on Thursday
even the labor party say they accept the
obr's figures so they accept that what I
announced is actually making the
recession shallower for families up and
down the country and so we were very
very careful to make sure that we got
that balance right but what people
wouldn't have wanted
is me not to take the decisions that
bring down inflation because the biggest
worry for families up and down the
country is seeing the cost of that
Weekly shop go up yeah and that's what I
wanted to make sure that we did
something about the average household is
going to be 1400 pounds worse off you
know there's a lost decade where living
standards fall back to levels uh not
seen since 2013 the sharpest fall in
household disposable incomes in over six
decades you can see why Jacob
rees-mogged described your Autumn
statement as a decision to lose you the
next election is that fair well I think
what people want from a conservative
government
is uh is a team of people who will take
the difficult decisions irrespective of
whether it's good for their political
fortunes because it's right for the
country and the plan that I announced
brings down inflation which is the
biggest worry for families up and down
the country it gets the economy growing
healthily and it helps people with their
energy bills with with one-off payments
and this year and the next year
particularly focusing on the most
vulnerable people you accept it's bad
for your political fortunes than this
Autumn statement no because I actually
think in the end that's why people vote
conservative because they trust us on
the economy to take difficult decisions
and that's what we've done and what tax
cuts in 2024 if you can well I would
like to bring down taxes as soon as it's
responsible but as a conservative faced
with a choice between sound money and
low taxes sound money has to come first
because inflation eats away at your
savings eats away at your salary far
more insidiously even than taxes chance
the final question because how can I not
ask when we are sitting on the site
where hs2 will be built talking about
sound money and I don't want to turn
this into the estimate vay interview
um but estimate vase also spoken about
hs2 arguing that it's too expensive many
of your colleagues you know have made
the argument as well you you no doubt
will tell me it's necessary for beast in
productivity and leveling up how much is
it going to cost
well Beth let me say this
um I as a conservative am committed to
spreading wealth and opportunity
throughout our whole country
and we have a very unbalanced economy
with much higher concentrations of
wealth and better paid jobs in London
and the southeast than in the rest of
the country the way you solve that is by
improving the connections between London
and the rest of the country so that we
can spread that wealth spread that
opportunity I've just been out uh
meeting one of the apprentices one of
the 1 000 apprentices working on the hs2
program it's an incredible program what
we're seeing from it is already
investment is happening in Birmingham
and in the West Midlands as companies
anticipate the the uplift that's going
to be created by hs2 so my message from
last Thursday was yes this is tough but
we aren't going to compromise on the
really big projects that make a
difference to our economy and hs2 is one
of those okay Chancellor thank you so
much thank you
Jeremy Hunt there in Colesville near
Birmingham and if you scan this QR code
on screen right now you can watch all of
our interviews online and all of the
previous episodes of the show and you
can also listen to the Beth Rigby
interviews podcast by scanning that QR
code on your screen now and new episodes
available each week as I take a look at
the highlights of the interviews and
there's some extra bits and pieces in
there too as we talk through politics
more generally that's on the Sky News
app or wherever you get your podcast
give it a try
well that's all for today's show thanks
so much for watching and thank you to
Jeremy Hunt for giving us some of his
time next week we're going to be back on
Tuesday at nine o'clock for a one-off
special show that you won't want to miss
so I hope to see you then
[Music]